Sony's game streaming service
PlayStation now is finally live allowing
you to stream retail and digital
PlayStation 3 games straight to your ps4
which normally lacks native support from
legacy console libraries PlayStation 4
is the first PlayStation now device to
graduate out of beta status in our early
tests indicate that Sony's actually off
to a great start the PlayStation now
service comes in two flavors monthly
subscriptions and individual game
rentals there are two subscription tiers
that offer unlimited access to over 100
PlayStation 3 games you can spend $20
for a single month or save 15 with a
three month commitment at $45 rental
pricing is more complicated and it
varies from game to game this is because
publishers ultimately have control over
pricing and rental periods in most cases
you can expect to pay as little as $2
for a 4 hour rental
most games offer 90-day rentals for $15
or less but there are a handful that
come in at higher price points nascar 14
cost $40 for 90 days and MotoGP 13 will
set you back 30 bucks
the worst offender however is f1 2013
which cost $50 to rent for 90 days some
games such as XCOM enemy within don't
even have a 90 day rental period oddly
XCOM is the most expensive game per day
at 30 dollars for 30 days I don't like
the looks of this because your streaming
games over the internet from Sony's
servers it's imperative that you not
only have a good internet connection but
also that your network at home is up to
the task according to Sony you need to
be able to download data at a rate of at
least 5 megabits per second anything
less you may experience choppy audio and
video rendering some games unplayable
we tested PlayStation now on a hard
wired network connection rated at 35
megabits per second and on a Wi-Fi
network rated at 10 megabits per second
what we found was that PlayStation now
works far better than expected even on
Wi-Fi I can't say that I had high hopes
of games both looking and playing well
but they did including late intensity
games like Super Street Fighter 4 Arcade
Edition which felt every bit as
responsive as it needed
granted I don't play on a competitive
level but I play enough Street Fighter
to understand the speed and rhythm of
certain characters and favorites like
Ibuki ryu and el fuerte felt the same as
they always have even on the slower
Wi-Fi connection so does that mean that
PlayStation now is a seamless experience
as as good as playing game straight from
the disc well it may be close but it's
not the same every game we played
exhibited video compression artifacts
groups of blurry pixels that result from
Sony reducing the bitrate of the raw
video so that it's fit for streaming on
most internet connections in most cases
the amount of artifacts on screen were
minimal and easy to ignore it's
prevalent during scenes with a lot of
grapes but generally speaking the
quality of sony's video stream is
sufficient and Mensa if you're worried
about online multiplayer fear not
because it works exactly as it would if
you were playing on an actual ps3
whether there are still people playing
older games online is another discussion
but on Sony's end it's done a good job
of preserving the experience of playing
with real Hardware in salt so in the
first week of Sony launching PlayStation
now it's proven to be a service that's
actually worth some of the costs
associated some games that can be had
for less than 10 bucks for 90 days for
example that's a pretty good deal of
course you also don't own this game it
is just a rental and if you're
subscribing you may have a limited
access for the amount of time but
eventually that subscription will also
go away and so will your access so it's
a question of value do you value games
as permanent objects that you can own or
do you want to pay a little bit of money
for an experience that you can have sort
of on a whim that's really where
PlayStation now fits in I suspect that
people will use this service probably
every PlayStation 4 owner at some point
it's just too convenient to rent a game
that maybe you've never played and I've
always wanted to I personally am NOT
going to be subscribing right away
but what I am going to do is check out
the rental service as it goes forward a
game like Final Fantasy 13 that I
haven't played since it came out I want
to revisit and you know what I don't
want to hook up my PlayStation 3 to my
TV because I don't have room for any
more contours so Sony has a long road
ahead of it for now it's just getting
started and it's going to come to many
more devices in probably the next few
months it's an open beta right now on
Vita and even PlayStation 3 if Sony can
fulfill their promise to bring you know
more consoles to now including
PlayStation 4 games PlayStation 1 and
PlayStation 2 games it's going to be a
service that's going to be really hard
for someone like Microsoft to meet
Nintendo on the other hand
maybe could do it they've got a huge
history of games behind them but are
they able to do that do they have the
technology in the know-how there knows
it took Sony to acquire Gaikai to make
it happen well stay tuned new games
watch comm for more PlayStation now
content as it develops